Locked in a, essentially it's
ego, but it's, it's a, it's, it's,
it's not an international
conversation. It's a, it's,
it's a game of, you know, who,
who is,
who is basically checking the right boxes
in their own little confirmation bias
to their own audience. And that doesn't
interest me, but it's frustrating.
You're all sorts of,
but you're also the best person on the
other side of that conversation now.
So there's a series of videos on Youtube,
I think it's called Merry Christmas,
Mr [inaudible]. Yeah, that's right. And
so on youtube you can watch for him,
pit it against people who are
playing this game. You know,
Islamists and jihadists are
various boards and that he,
Majid is meeting them on your interview
show is mostly in the UK where they're
pretending to be more benign than they
are. And that, and Majid, as you know,
finding the question that sort of pulls
back the mask on the theocrat and it's,
it's hilarious. It's very funny that
one video that you publish on your blog.
I've sent to dozens of my friends that
one video where there's this guy and he's
addressing this enormous group of people
and he's talking about is this radical
Islam or is this Islam that that was I
think a conference in Norway that was
just,
I mean,
these dots straight up in his limits
and jihad is addressing a crowd of
seemingly mainstream Muslims in Norway.
But he just by show of hands, you know,
is it, are we extremist if we think
a stage should be killed? It's,
it's pretty, it's stunning. It's
an amazing documentary. Yeah.
And respect to the way they want to
treat homosexuals, pos dates. I mean,
the whole thing is,
is this Islam or is this radical
Islam talking of ideology blinkering
statistical data on the
subject of homosexuality.
So in the United Kingdom,
a poll was done last year asking,
so there've been two poles gauging
public Muslim attitudes towards guys. Uh,
the first asked how many Muslims in
the UK find homosexuality is morally
acceptable and 0%.
This is by the way,
by professional polling company.
It's not just some student
that's devised a poll on Twitter.
A professional polling company found
that 0% of British Muslims responded to a
poll saying that they found
homosexuality morally acceptable.
And then a year later, which
now last year, another poll,
uh, was, uh, was conducted.
And uh, that was uh, an ICM poll
asking, uh, where the British Melissa,
how many British Muslims believe that
homosexuality should be criminalized or
remain legal. And uh, I think
it was roughly 52%, 52%,
if my memory serves me correctly,
said of British Muslims said that they
would wish for homosexuality to be
criminalized.
And of course,
what does criminalization of homosexuality
mean under Sharia and traditional
Islamic jurisprudence?
We know that it's punished by death.
So these are these, this is scientific
data from gauging, you know,
attitudes. British wasn't an
attitude towards homosexuality,
but the ideological blinkers will,
will kick in and refuse to see that truth.
And these aren't, Islam is unfortunately
my dialogue with Sam. We talk this,
that there are the Islamists who want to,
who actively wants to take over a country
and enforce their version of Islam.
Then there's underneath that there's a,
a softer landing of very,
very conservative stroke fundamentalist
attitudes that unfortunately have become
widespread.
And here is an example of it that is,
that is being gauged by scientific polling
methodology that tells us there's a
problem. And unfortunately if one
were to speak in this way, um,
especially in, in Europe, uh,
one is received by my own political
tribe and that's liberals center left and
further.
One is met with denial and called a
bigot simply for re relaying these facts.
A quarter of British Muslims when asked
about the massacre at the Charlie Hebdo
offices in Paris a quarter said
that those attacks are justifiable.
They sympathize with the attackers as
opposed to the victims who were the staff
at the Charlie Hebdo offices.
So this is what led you to be
put on the southern poverty law,
speaking in these terms. And
unfortunately it's reporting polling data.
And what it does for me is to say,
this is why it's so important
to address these issues,
to have these conversations,
to try and empower those Muslim voices
that are seeking to challenge this sort
of, these sorts of attitudes and, and
carve out a space. And if, you know,
if,
if one can do that with Catholicism in
Europe and go through a reformation and
end up with an enlightenment and
ended up with secularism in the West,
what I often say is American
liberals are very happy,
challenging their own Bible belt.
And yet we have a core,
an belt within our communities.
And if I'm attempting to replicate the
equivalent of challenging the Bible belt
within Muslim communities,
it means addressing these issues.
And yet they grant to themselves the
right to challenge the Bible belt within
America. And yet, if we were
to challenge what I call the,
an belt in Europe were suddenly
called bigots. Um, you know,
and Islamophobes is this,
is this static has been moving,
has it been adjusting and changing?
Is there any sort of a recognition that
there's an issue with this? So you know,
the emergence of Isis really did bring
it to the fore and it really did quiet
and some of the voices,
it also did increase the hysteria from
the far left because they began panicking
thinking,
actually we're going to lose this debate.
And that's where I noticed their
labeling became even stronger.
But the emergence of Isis did
wake up a lot of people to,
to the challenges we're facing here
because so many European born and raised
Muslims went over to join isis. And of
course think about it in this sense,
the most infamous and notorious execution
sell that I think were erroneously
called the jihadi beetles in the
press because actually it really does.
It's an insult to the Beatles,
but it was a diminishes the true
horror of these guys. You know,
they call him Jihadi John and,
but the isis execution is basically that
entire cell of the media face of Isis
execution cell.
We're all British Muslims.
And that should tell you something that
we've got the worst terrorist group
educator. I mean, the thing
is a university graduate
like every variable that the,
that the far left wants to marshal to
explain this phenomenon like lack of
educational opportunity, lack of economic
opportunity, lack of social integration,
mental illness. Uh, you, you can,
you can find people who had
massive opportunity. I missed that.
You weren't getting, you weren't a
jihadist, but you are an Islamist.
But let me Europe person who,
that's where I can basically play
in a game he wanted to me, you're,
you're like a, he's, he's,
he's, he's somebody who back
to the superman. He can run,
he can run for political office. He
hasn't been elected yet, but he, you know,
he should be, I mean this is the
quarterback of the football team.
Ian. This context is a
candidate for recruitment. Well,
thesis, think of, think of it this way.
We've got the worst terrorist group in
our lifetime. It one can reasonably say,
is Isis, right? The worst terrorist
group, at least in living memory,
is isis and the worst cell,
you know,
it's the execution cell came from a
fully developed for once of a better own
fuss, wild country. And that was
Britain and Mohammed. I'm Waze.
The leader of that execution
sell, graduated from the
University of Westminster,
was given as a young child,
was given political asylum by Britain
because his family were Kuwaiti and they
fled the invasion of
Kuwait by Saddam Hussein,
the country that the west liberated.
And he turned against that country.
So he had every reason to like Britain.
Britain gave my home,
gave him or actually physically
bricks and mortar house,
gave his family on social costs that gave
him social housing. They educated him.
He graduated from university and they
liberated his father's country from an
aggressor.
And this man turned against this country
that helped him and his family and his
nation. Was he captured or did he do,
he's dead. One of them has been captured,
but uh, he's currently being
held in Turkey. I would,
it would be fascinating to listen to.
His rationale is it was not so that
the other one, I forgot his name,
but he was just interviewing
you don't get a lot out of him.
He was interviewed by female Arab
journalist. You Watch that? No,
that was ever happened there. And so on
and dismissive character. Yeah. Yeah. He,
he, he refused to talk about
much. He said, uh, you know,
these are accurate accusations and
allegations that you're making,
and I will wait to trial. Uh, in the
end, he kind of cut the interview short.
He seemed a little put out that she
was a woman. As I'm looking at you now,
imagine she's the interviewer and,
and,
and she's asking me questions and
I'm looking in this direction in your
direction. He'll literally never
laid eyes on her and it, yeah,
it's bad.
And LP.